okay rolling test test one two
[Music]
my name is Anna zairuznea and I'm a
music historian
music is the most ephemeral Thing music
gets older faster than anything else
there's a Gaia Johannes tinctores who
said in the 1460s that music older than
40 years isn't worth listening to in the
1460s and if you think about the music
your parents listen to maybe that's not
your music music is so tied to the
moment in which it's written in first
performed given that isn't it crazy that
we have music surviving from the Middle
Ages
[Music]
I study music history because it gives
us a way to get at aspects of the past
that I don't think are available to us
through any other means there's
something about music that is linked to
the emotions that's linked to the body
that's linked to the voices that sing it
or the instruments that play it there's
something so personal embodied about
music
[Music]
if you hear that music then and it
sounds so weird for me that's the moment
that's interesting right is to then keep
listening and say okay well I think that
sounds weird
but clearly they thought it was awesome
so what kind of a subject would I need
to be to think that this is awesome and
what kinds of insights then can I gain
into what it means to be human what it
means to be a listener
often music manuscripts would get
chopped up and they would get used to
reinforce other bindings so you'd have a
book from the 17th century or something
that would have as part of its binding
material a piece of music from the 13th
century and you have to figure out
what's been cut off in terms of words
and notes and piece it all together
[Music]
thank you
there are a couple of pieces of music
that I've reconstructed from The 14th
Century that once I was done with them
we could sing them in ways that we had
never sung them before
I think that's sort of what it comes
down to for me is to find this music
that feels foreboding because it's in a
different notation because it's in these
sources that are in these European
archives it's full of wormholes you know
it's decaying the pages are falling off
it's it can be a mess and to restore it
in some sense to turn it into something
that can tell us something about a
person who lived once and how they might
have experienced the world
what is this music connected to is it
just a floating song no music is always
for somebody from somebody for some
purpose so what was its purpose that's
one of the that's one of the things
we're doing but also it's a question of
what we can learn about ourselves
theorizing a whole bunch of new pitches
um and we have a way to rotate really
really fast those things to the Italians
yes it seems very much as you said like
music about itself
foreign
I hope that my students come out of my
classes inspired to listen more
carefully especially when they hear
something that they don't like I never
ask anybody to like the things we study
I just ask them to sort of attend to
them carefully and I think the act of
attending carefully to something that
sounds strange
is a life skill
[Music]